Boris, please, you decide your wife for a long time
buy a dog especially for this case
Good family strengthens the world
directly and definitely Russian troops on
Ukraine is not today Iranian partners
demonstrate
very great flexibility obvious desire
reach a compromise on this Iranian
nuclear program
he was a lariska opposition and
stones and authorities in general although they were wearing socks
good enough relationship then when
we are with him in general and would not like mister
Putin to become un secretary-general
no future owned 1
would you like to clone yourself or
recruit an army of twins and then we
Russian officials other than officials
you no one
right away